je passe tout de suite à notre second
débat directement liée à la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la situation
dans les hôpitaux publics français les
premières auditions elles ont lieu la
semaine dernière et face à la cinquième
vague de kobe de 19 c'est tout l'édifice
qui menace de s'effondrer flora sauvage
à deux semaines des fêtes de fin d'année
la pression s'accroît sur l'hôpital on
compte actuellement plus de 14 mille
malades ducobu 19 hospitalisés et de
1600 personnes en soins critiques le
directeur général des hôpitaux de paris
propose une incitation financière aux
soignants qui acceptent de décaler leurs
congés auditionné au sénat la semaine
dernière le président de la fédération
hospitalière de france frédéric
valletoux a rappelé les fragilités de
l'hôpital qui existait déjà avant la
crise duco vite 19 il faut rappeler que
l'hôpital a abordé la crise avec 30% de
postes de praticiens hospitaliers
vacants il faut rappeler que les
tensions sur les recrutements toucher
aussi les deux infirmiers infirmières
les postes d'aides-soignants bref qu à
tous les étages de l'hôpital les
tensions sur les effectifs étaient déjà
le quotidien des établissements bien
avoir la crise pour éviter un
engorgement huit régions ont activé
leurs plans blancs il permet de
déprogrammer des opérations de
réquisitionner du personnel de reporter
leur plongée et de rappeler certains
soignants en vacances une situation
tendue alors que les soignants estime
que le ségur de la santé le plan pour
l'hôpital qui devait revaloriser les
métiers n'a pas porté ses fruits quand
le médicament n'est pas bon quand le
ségur et ben c'est pas le bon médicament
c'est tout monsieur véran il faut
changer de médicament une infirmière de
nuit elle gagne 1 euro de l'heure un
euro de l'heure les français doivent le
savoir parce que les soignants qui sont
encore en place ils en ont marre aussi
ils vont offrir pas repartir et à jour
on aura un système de santé sans
soignants alors que depuis 2000 13 27
mille lits d'hôpitaux ont été supprimés
en france aujourd'hui un lit sur cinq
est fermés faute de personnel pour ne
pas surcharger l'hôpital le président de
la fédération hospitalière de france
frédéric valletoux appelle les médecins
libéraux à reporter leurs congés de fin
d'année
l'hôpital public français en grand
danger voilà le thème de notre
je vous présente mes invités véronic
guillotin bon soit vous êtes médecin
sénatrice radicale de meurthe-et-moselle
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales est membre de cette
commission d' enquête dont on parlait
commission d'enquêté du sénat sur la
situation de nos hôpitaux j'accueille
également ben jama rossi bonsoir soir
bienvenue vous êtes infectiologues au
centre hospitalier intercommunal
d'aulnay sous bois et vous publiez en
première ligne c'est chez prisma édition
frédéric bizarrement soir bienvenue vous
aussi professeur d'économie brillant
l'institut santé votre livre l'autonomie
solidaire en santé la seule réforme
public possible c'est aux éditions
michalon laetitia cru pas été évidemment
rester à mes côtés ces auditions de la
commission denquête elles reprennent le
16 ce jeudi au sénat avec je crois les
représentants des services d'urgence
c'est ça je vous propose ce lien
d'écouté à un autre extrait on en a eu
certains dans le reportage mais d'une
audition qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière c'était celle de patrick goudot
et vice-président de l'intersyndicat
national des praticiens hospitaliers
n'espérait que segura les résoudre tous
les maux sont accrus que l'hôpital
d'après serait pas comme l'hôpital
d'avant non non il est pas tout à fait
comme avant il est bien nous sommes en
réalité face aux conséquences d'une
spirale négative d'ing qui est mise en
exergue qui a été mise en exergue par le
cos vide après la leyre des collectifs
intérieur gens s'interrogent pitallier
qui avait précédé ce cet événement cette
pandémie et cette situation donc a
conduit à la démission nombreux partis
siens y compris parmi nos rangs
hospitalo universitaire avec toutes les
conséquences que ça représente en
matière de formation de recherche etc la
situation est pire qu'avant la crise qu
vidé ce que véronique guillotin c'est la
taule in tonalité générale des premières
auditions oui c'est la tonalité générale
je pense que c'est pas que des auditions
d'ailleurs ce qu'on entend sur le
terrain dans les hôpitaux chez les
jeunes voilà on sent bien qu'on
redémarre cette crise qui est une crise
assez violentes et la situation des
effectifs à l'hôpital est inférieure à
ce qu'elle était avant la première crise
donc ça rend les choses plus compliquées
et parler de spirale négative c'est ce
que je dis toujours effectivement moi ya
de monde plus c'est compliqué plus a
fait perdre les gens plus a fait fuir
les gens enfin les personnels et du coup
sûr une période de crise mais voilà on
est dans une situation aujourd'hui fin
dramatique dans les hôpitaux failli
bizarre vous parlez souvent de la perte
de sens à l'hôpital ça aussi ça
s'aggrave d'une certaine façon ce que je
viens de décrire la sénatrice oui
absolument moi ce qui me frappe quand
même c'est le la forme d'impuissance
politique on a vraiment l'impression que
c'est pas propre au gouvernement mais on
a l'impression que la classe politique
est impuissante face à ce problème
d'abord on était j'ai été frappé par le
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale qui quand même et historiquement
montre un déséquilibre durable des
comptes sociaux en pleine crise du
système de santé avec un système de
retraites dont on n'a échoué que l'on a
échoué donc là on est finalement sans
qu'il y ait de débat de fond on peut
être d'accord ou pas d'accord et sans
qu'il y ait de solution proposée est là
c'est la même chose finalement on voit
bien que au delà et la visite par
exemple du premier ministre au chu de
strasbourg il ya deux jours montre cette
impuissance politique prémunissent
t'arriver dire écoutez je vais sauver
l'hôpital je vais rajouter 20 millions
d'euros parce que l'hôpital était au
bord du désastre station vraiment de
strasbourg de strasbourg était de
strasbourg et donc uni veille et sans
aucune solution sans aucune espoirs dont
qui a forcé - des parce que c'est pas
aux médecins de régler les médecins doit
être partie prenante pour régler cette
solution met donc il faut bien quand
même que les politiques est une vision
d'avenir de l'hôpital public mais du
prochain modèle de santé parce que la
crise est d sera montagne où l'hôpital
public qui était au coeur du modèle de
45 notamment avec les ordonnances de
bris en fait est l'épicentre d'une crise
mais qui est systémique donc à la fois
la crise systémique et la solution est
systémique et donc il faut on ne
trouvera pas de solution au sein de
l'hôpital public qui voit bien que tout
se désagrège et qui en plus à une crise
sanitaire dans la crise systémique qui
fait que la en effet on est dans une
situation très grave du fait de la crise
sanitaire mais c'est pas la crise
sanitaire qui a mis par terre l'hôpital
public et puis évidemment on développera
cet aspect c'est la crise systémique et
éventuellement des des solutions
d'épilation si on met une souris revenir
benjamin aussi à ce que voulait dire en
fait les hôpitaux se sont sont
maintenant responsables de leur dette
d'une certaine façon quand quand le
prémunissent dit je viens sauver
l'hôpital de strasbourg c'est un peu de
ça je sais pas c'est comment comment ça
se passe chez vous ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire qu'il ya du matériel que
vous pouvez pas à commander acheté par
la barre oui oui en fait nous on avait
commencé à faire un mouvement sur
l'hôpital pendant le mois de juillet
2019 puisqu'on a un hôpital et j'en
parle dans le livre on a un hôpital qui
est soi-disant sans papiers donc ça veut
dire que tout est informatisé et les
ordonnances de sortir par l'informateur
par la parole à l'ordinateur on n'avait
plus qu'à tout genre et le prestataire
ne pouvait pas livré les cartouches
d'encre et s'ils n'avaient pas été payés
par l'hôpital depuis trois ans donc en
fait pendant la crise covivo s'est
retrouvé en manque de gaz du sang donc
c'est un test un réactif qui nous permet
de mesurer le taux d'oxygénation des
patients on peut comprendre que pendant
la crise que vit de première vague ne
plus pour avoir deux gars du sens à
cette problématique on avait pu
découvrir on pouvait plus payer
découvrions pour vous donc en fait on a
eu une série comme ça donc de blocage on
a des problèmes de pour affréter les
médicaments donc l'hôpital est
défaillant on réussit pas à commander du
nouveau matériel tout est vétuste on a
plus de couette on a plus de petits
calculs hier
il faut quand même comprendre que les
gens qui se lancent comme les
infirmières les aide soignante pour
s'occuper des gens ils ont au coeur
l'idée de prendre en charge les gens
bien et des gens qui ont une mentalité
qui est plutôt empathique et c'est pour
ça qu'ils font ce métier quand on leur
dit ben en fait ils se font insulter par
les patients parce qu'il ya pas de cuir
passe cas pas de passes cas pas de
couverture parce qu'il fait froid parce
qu'à pas de chauffage pas ce qu a pâti
etc ils ont l'impression d'être
maltraitant ça les met dans une
situation d'impuissance est forcément
forcément il part ils partent donc en
fait le problème de l'hôpital public et
un problème de de salaire il ya un
problème aussi de disparités mais ça on
pourra peut-être en parlais tout à
l'heure entre entre l'argent public
qu'on donne aux privés et l'argent
public qu'on donne au public puisque ça
c'est quand même assez aberrant et ça
fait partir quand même un bon nombre de
soignants et de médecins surtout mais il
ya aussi un problème de en fait
d'environnement c'est à dire qu on a à
un moment fait il ya une loi qui a été
fait en 2002 8 qui fait que l'ensemble
du budget d'un hôpital l'hôpital se paye
en facturant un maximum à la sécurité
sociale les actes qui sont faits c'est
pareil pour les cliniques etc sauf que
l'hôpital ne choisit pas les actes
puisqu'il doit en fait on sait qu'à une
inégalité à une des spécialités qui sont
plus rentables que loeb que d'autres a
donc les hôpitaux qui vont faire de
l'argent vont se spécialiser dans les
actes les plus rentables et des poissons
il ya des patients avec ses grilles qui
sont plus rentables que d'autres donc
ils vont ils vont choisir les patients
les plus rentables le privé va choisir
voilà et donc
sa part va prendre sa part en facturant
avec des as qui ne sont pas qu'est-ce
qui se passe le trou de la sécurité
sociale qui disparaît puisque l'assiette
est est répartie un peu comme ça est en
fête et mis dans tous les hôpitaux de
france et navarre et donc en fait tous
les hôpitaux de france sont surendettés
ils ne peuvent plus rien payer ils ne
peuvent plus payer leur personnel faut
quand même voir que dans notre service
on parle de deux fils des soignants mais
des titulaires enfin iliad et il ya des
soignants qui sont là depuis 10 ans 11
ans et qui sont pas titulaires et donc
c'est à dire qu'ils sont bloqués dans
leurs grilles de salaires échelon 1 ça
veut dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir de
progression et depuis dix ans ils sont
pas titularisés et l'hôpital maintenant
les ars 10 bat titulariser les mets
l'hôpital n'a pas l'argent pour les
titulariser et l'état ne donne pas
l'argent à l'hôpital pour pouvoir le
faire donc on est dans une situation
d'impuissance alors j'aimerais vous
présenter prisca thévenot qui vient de
nous rejoindre qui est porte-parole
évidemment de
de la république en marche merci d'être
avec nous dans cette émission
vous avez peut-être entendu s'cusez
frédéric bise à tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que ça va bien au delà de ce
quinquennat ou de ce gouvernement mais
est-ce qu'il ya pas eu quand même avec
le ségur et avec finalement ce contexte
inédit historique de crise sanitaire une
petite ou une grande occasion manquée
pour tout remettre à plat et lancer
cette grande réforme
alors effectivement je rejoins ce qui a
été dit avancé que la crise sanitaire a
mis en exergue des difficultés qui
existent depuis longtemps sur le système
de santé le système de santé
effectivement hospitalier mais également
les systèmes de santé en ville
maintenant l'objet n'est effectivement
pas de chercher des responsables mais
plutôt de trouver des solutions et je
peux pas dire qui on peut que le c ur de
la santé est une occasion manquée
puisqu'elle apporte quand même des
réponses des réponses sur
l'investissement et le désendettement
des hôpitaux comme le docteur viennent
le dire juste avant des investissements
aussi en matériel en matériel du
quotidien pour que celles et ceux qui
n'ont pour soigner au quotidien puissent
travailler dans des situations dignes
des rebelles au risation salariale etc
maintenant est ce qu'il s'agit de dire
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit de se
satisfaire de tout cela est de se dire
que c'est bon tout est fait et qu'on n'a
plus qu'a avancé nous je pense qu'il
s'agit d'une première étape et
d'ailleurs les annonces qui se suivent
sur le segment de la santé se poursuivre
pas plus tard que je crois que c'était
la semaine dernière olivier verront
continue d'ailleurs ce travail avec les
fédérations représentant en ayant signé
un protocole d'accord pour justement
travailler dans le détail très précis
des modalités de mise en place des
réformes de financement donc on voit que
ce travail c'est le début d'un long
cheminement qui bien évidemment a
commencé dès l'année dernière avec la
crise sanitaire qui a rappelé que
l'urgence était d'agir très rapidement
mais ce n'est pas fini ça doit se
poursuivre mais je vais vous redonner la
parole vous pourrez réagir évidemment
prisca t nommé frédéric bizarre c'est
pas la grande réforme dont vous parlez
c'est pas la remise à plat dont vous
parlez non alors à la fois le le ségur
de la santé était je pense nécessaire
pour faire passer cette crise sanitaire
à l'hôpital qui véritablement risquait
de devoir une fuite de ses ressources
humaines du fait d'un découragement
quand vous augmenter la charge de
travail sur un personnel qui est déjà
assez démotivés et qui est mal payé
forcément la voyelle donc moi je gagne
quand même mais assisté en partie à
cette fuite donc
jusqu'à maintenant mais je donc jeudi
après je vais vous dire ce que je pense
qu'ils étaient insuffisantes d'abord il
a été mal ficelée parce que je pense que
de donner à tout le monde quel que soit
son sa compétence la même somme d'argent
est une fausse bonne idée de ne pas
avoir été revalorisé les tâches pénibles
la pénibilité qui est extrêmement
importante à l'hôpital est une erreur
profonde en tant qu il ya eu des erreurs
dans ce fait ça mais il était nécessaire
maintenant est ce que c'est la réforme
structurelle qui va permettre à
l'hôpital de sortir de la crise
certainement pas certainement pas
personne de sérieux ne peut dire ça
juste deux choses
l'hôpital je pense qu'après 20 ans de
crise à l'hôpital parce que ses vingt
ans de crise à l'hôpital on voit bien
que la vie à l'hôpital se dégradent les
conditions sociales se dégrade à
l'hôpital et notamment à l'hôpital
public même si on viendra sur cette
opposition
public privé qui est à mon avis assez
stérile mais en tout cas il ya une crise
depuis 20 ans donc faut peut-être se
poser la question si l'état et le bon
gestionnaire si l'état est vraiment un
bon manager un bon gestionnaire de
l'hôpital public peut-être qu'il faut
repenser la gouvernance et le peut-être
c'est qu'il faut certainement repenser
la gouvernance qu'avon qu'avons nous
fait depuis 20 ans en gros on a augmenté
cette étatisation qui se traduit par une
bureaucratisation sans fin et on a des
médicalisé la gouvernance dans l'hôpital
c'est à dire qu'on a de bons à penser
que le problème c'était que les médecins
avaient trop de pouvoir au sein de
l'hôpital d'accord donc finalement le
médecin se retrouve en effet sans réel
pouvoir donc l'administration décidé
organise mais ça on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est pas très surprenant
d'ailleurs mais on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas donc à la fois
l'extérieur de l'hôpital il faut
repenser la place de l'état ça s'éteint
c'est un sujet éminemment politique quel
doit être le rôle de l'état demain dans
le futur système de santé c'est
certainement pas de s'occuper de
l'organisation des services de l'hôpital
psy après ses vingt ans de crise on n'a
pas compris que c'est pas à l'hôpital de
gérer l'hôpital public ça veut pas dire
que le pire ne le sait pas mais
attardons non ça veut pas dire encore
une fois que l'état doit se retirer doit
pas avoir l'état il doit être stratégie
doit être régulateur doit s'assurer met
à l'essai toute cette autonomie
hospitalière d'ailleurs dont on parle
beaucoup dans les discours il est
peut-être temps de la transition constat
qui est partagé ouais ce que dit et ce
que dit monsieur s'est partagé par
beaucoup de candidats à l'élection
présidentielle s'est partagé depuis 20
ans il ya vraisemblablement un problème
d'organisation dans l'hôpital de
gouvernance andy sneap disco les
candidats les candidats ils le disent
puisque arnaud montebourg dit par
exemple à gauche il dit oui il y à 30 %
de personnel dans les hôpitaux qui sont
chargés de contrôler des autres oui
c'est 35 6 35 secondes administratif
voilà c'est 30% il faut peut-être les
remettre au contact des des malades à un
bon contact des soignants pour les aider
valérie pécresse dit exactement la même
chose et dis moi je vais embaucher 25
mille soignants supplémentaires dans
l'hôpital sur cinq en tout temps des
bureaucrates is an parce que
effectivement il n'y a pas assez de
monde en première ligne pour reprendre
un peu le champ lexical du président
pendant la pandémie donc il faut plus de
personnel vraiment aux côtés des malades
etc c'est ce problème là dans l'hôpital
bon marine le pen elle dit que et
effectivement il ya eu la non
compensation des 35 heures que les
immigrés étouffe les systèmes comme eric
zemmour mais elle parle aussi d'une par
exemple d'une fraude à la carte vitale
qui est responsable de la faillite de
l'hôpital donc voyez ça c'est des
petites mesures qui sont vraiment
original par rapport au corpus qui est
vraiment unanime à qui et c'est un bloc
tous tous tous à gauche comme à droite
qui veulent augmenter les salaires pour
lutter contre la pénurie ils veulent en
finir avec le numerus clausus est
toujours plus forte
à toi emmanuel macron le veut aussi
emmanuel macron l'a proposé aussi pour
le ségur de la santé c'est ça qui est
incompréhensible en été
on y va alors sur le côté administratif
puis je suis d'accord qu'il ya trop
d'administratifs et pas s est fait dans
un hôpital et que les stratégistes quand
vous me dites que vous manquez de
cartouches d'encre il ya 30% apparemment
d'administratifs en trop ils sont pas
capables de commander des cartons et
jamais ils n'ont pas de lui n'ont pas le
budget c'est juste un problème de buté
mais il ya un problème à la fois
d'administratifs effectivement je pense
qu'il ya c'est trop tard une lettre
administrative mais ce n'est pas le seul
problème il faut changer le système de
rémunération il faut qu'on arrête de
faire une rémunération à l'activité on
peut pas être on peut pas gérer la santé
comme on gère une entreprise de manière
de du business c'est à dire la
tarification à l'acte des tarifications
à l'acte on peut pas dire ans et quand
xavier bertrand a été mis en place en
fait ça existe ça a commencé a commencé
en 2001 et après ça a terminé en 2008 et
eu deux volets c'est pour lui pour les
hôpitaux 1 mais on peut prendre on peut
enfin moi j'ai travaillé dans des jets
travailler dans des cliniques et j'ai
travaillé dans des établissements qui
fonctionnaient un peu manière différente
et on peut pas dire à quelqu'un vous
allez gagner 30 euros de consultation si
vous opérez pas et 1200 si vous opérez
ça il ya un biais il ya un biais qui se
fait que la personne va plus faire
certaines interventions il ya un biais
inflationnistes qui est fait de cette
tarification ça pousse à faire des actes
qui sont pas forcément nécessaire ça
pour ça rajouter des examens qui sont
pas nécessaires ils sont en train de par
exemple de privatiser nous notre notre
système de radiologie de sur l'hôpital
d'accord un scanner thoraco avoue ne pas
bien quand il tord axa abdomen pelvis
c'est on va dire sans au thorax seuls
ses 80 euros abdomen pelvis et 80 euros
donc ils vont faire revenir le patient
deux fois pour faire l'examen double
irradiation pour pouvoir gagner plus
d'argent c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne une tarification à l'activité
et donc c'est pas efficients ça ira dit
deux fois le malade saint-jacques deux
fois le produit contraste c'est
dangereux pour le patient donc c'est pas
dans l'intérêt du malade donc il ya
aussi un problème une réflexion qu'il
faut qu'on est tous de manière
collective sur le système de
rémunération des mets des soignants
alors se proposera quant à calmer nos
deux nouveaux jeux vous donnait la
parole juste après
il est temps parce que vous allez nous
faire bon soir quand un bis but
justement à un point un peu plus
détaillée des premières auditions devant
la commission d'enquêté du sénat tout
avait fait monter à l'origine de cette
commune oui voilà c'est ce que je vais
vous proposer de remonter à l'origine
elle est venue des d'une demande dlr
cette commission d'enquêté est le point
de départ c'est un chiffre que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure thomas cse 20% de
lit qui sont bien fermés faute de
soignants dans les grands hôpitaux
publics c'est ce chiffre qui avait été
donnée par le conseil scientifique qui a
fait réagir jusque donc au sénat y avait
que cette demande de commission enquête
alors ce chiffre on le sent il est
contesté par le gouvernement et il
interroge quand même sur l'état notre
santé notre système de santé en france
et donc la première étape jeudi dernier
c'était effectivement d'auditionner les
représentants des personnels soignants
est effectivement comme vous l'avez déjà
un peu évoqué à leur constat est sans
appel sur la situation de l'hôpital au
delà même de la gestion de l'épidémie de
cause il ya une situation qui date comme
ça depuis plusieurs années et surtout
ces départs massifs de soignants qui ont
été décrits comme des vagues de départ
pendant les auditions et qui sont
directement liés à des décisions
budgétaires y compris des décisions
budgétaires récente vous parlez de la
loi de finances celle qui était examinée
l'année dernière et bien ça ça a eu des
conséquences directes écoutez un
représentant des infirmiers
830 millions d'économies imposées aux
hôpitaux pour la performance interne 215
millions d'euros d'économies imposées
aux hôpitaux pour structurer les
parcours de soins efficient qui a
entraîné donc une deuxième vague de
départs d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants depuis le 1er juin 21
qui est énorme à savoir que
les lits qui ont été fermés l'été
pour permettre aux agents de partir en
vacances n'ont pas pu être ouverts ces
syndicats et collectifs ils pointent
deux choses dans ces auditions déjà la
tarification à l'acte 1 vous venez aussi
de l'évoquer à la t2a comme on dit
également long dames c'est à cet
objectif qui a été fixé et qui existe
depuis les années 90 est aussi c'est une
contrainte pour ces établissements où
pourrait être y revenir écoutez la
représentante du collectif inter
hôpitaux c'est ce collectif qui était né
en 2019 avant même la crise du coc vide
il en résulte une nécessité d'économies
or les économies se font majoritairement
sur le personnel soignant qui reste la
principale variable d'ajustement
alors que des études scientifiques ont
démontré que la mortalité des patients
augmente dès qu'une infirmière doit
s'occuper de plus de six patients de
jour ou de nuit dans un service
d'hospitalisation standard dans nos
hôpitaux il n'est pas rare qu'une
infirme heures doivent s'occuper de
seize patients en journée voire 24 la
nuit des personnels soignants variable
d'ajustement budgétaire sont des propos
qui sont revenus à plusieurs reprises
thomas dans le sens aux auditions et la
commission qui a également auditionné
les les présidents de fédérations
d'établissements et alors là c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils ont donné des
précisions sur le manque de soignants
oui on en revient à ce chiffre vous
savez qui a déclenché la commission
denquête qu'elle voit la véracité dans
ces chiffres et bien frédéric valletoux
le président de la fédération des
hôpitaux publics il a parlé pts au lieu
de 2 6% de lits fermés en moyenne faute
de soignants un chiffre déjà énorme des
dit-il lui pendant son audition mais ce
taux il dit aussi qu'il peut monter
encore beaucoup plus dans certains
établissements dans le privé alors là on
parle pas de lits fermés le représentant
des hôpitaux privés parle plutôt de 10 %
des infirmières qui manquent à l'appel
mais il tient à nuancer ces chiffres sur
le manque de personnel écoutez laminé
gharbi
pas les mêmes tensions mafia mais il
nous manque 10 % féminin donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh bien on essaie d'être
inventif imaginatif et de travailler
quelquefois on dans la difficulté est ce
qu'on appelle j'aime pas ce mot mais en
mode dégradé on est obligé mais aucun
patient qui sera présenté à nos portes
au fait quand même 54% de chirurgie 39%
la cancérologie aucun patient n'a été
refusé aucun aucun et les chiffons sur
la balle à l'ailé en tout cas c'était
les premières auditions elle continue
cette semaine vous l'avez dit mais en
tout cas on voit déjà qu'une sénatrice
pendant ses auditions a parlé d'un
constat lourd difficile avec des
problématiques très vaste une situation
tellement complexe qu'on ne sait pas par
quel bout prendre la chose en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire le
sénat puisqu'il a donc six mois pour
travailler autour de la situation de
l'hôpital et du ce thème de santé en
général puisque c'est aussi là dessus
que va élargir le sénat merci beaucoup
merci quentin pour toutes ces précisions
véronique guillotin à quoi ça sert au
delà donc voila ca on est vraiment dans
le travail de la représentation
parlementaire c'est c'est passionnant et
c'est aussi de la pédagogie vis-à-vis de
nos téléspectateurs mais ça peut
déboucher sur quoi des propositions je
l'espère mais moi je voudrais redire
quand on parle de la crise de l'hôpital
public mais c'est la crise d'un système
de santé dans sa globalité l'hôpital
public alors on avait parlé de l'hôpital
privé je partage complètement il ya
c'est lié à la halle à la tarification
il ya des services dans certains
hôpitaux privés qui ont énormément
d'argent ou en tout cas qui récupère
beaucoup d'argent de la sécu parce que
c'est des ac rémunérateur une
tarification à l'acte alors que des
services par exemple dans l'hôpital
public vont s'occuper de temps en temps
faire les mêmes actes m'avoir des
patients plus compliqué plus âgés plus
dépendants au lieu de les garder deux
jours ils vont les garder quatre jours
ça va se compliquer derrière c'est une
tarification qui n'est plus du tout
adaptée donc ça c'est une première chose
moi j'ai l'air j'irai aux et aussi aux
hôpitaux privés à but non lucratif sur
certains territoires il ya qu' il n'y a
pas de concurrence neisseria n'y a pas
d'hopital public à côté de certains
expliquent etc ils sont dans la même
situation difficulté aujourd'hui est à
tout ça il faut rajouter la ville il
faut rajouter la ville le lien entre la
ville et l'hôpital parce qu'on a aussi
une crise de la médecine de ville et des
soignants à domicile on veut faire moins
d'offres diminué en fait la durée
d'hospitalisation mais pour ça il faut
qu'en aval on est les équipes mobilisées
et tout ça c'est une réelle
problématique alors il imprime de
tarification moi je pense que c'est un
système aujourd'hui qui doit être vu et
vous l'avez dit le plfss hormis
l'augmentation des dépenses et
l'augmentation des recettes lié à l'as à
la conjoncture de la crise qu vide ce
que l'on peut dire quand même c'est si
on se projette et c'est ce que l'on nous
a montré si on se projette dans quatre
cinq ans on a un déficit encore qui est
structurelle et on paie et on a et on
voit pas en fait de mesures qui pour
corriger ce déficit structurel donc je
pense que le grand ségur qui a été
annoncé nous a annoncé des
revalorisations salariales c'est bien
des reprises de dette de les autres des
hôpitaux c'est bien de l'un vis ce
moment c'est bien mais moi mon avis
c'est pas suffisant c'est à dire ces
mesures je vous donne ma parole je
voudrais juste me tourner vers prisca
thévenoud une dernière fois parce que
vous vous devez partir dans dans une
minute je rappelle les chiffres de ducey
y aurait la santé 8,2 milliards de
hausses de salaires 19 milliards
d'investissements sur sur dix ans je
reviens à la question de la grande de la
grande réforme est ce que finalement ça
ça pourrait être dans le
le programme d'un candidat d'un futur
candidat emmanuel macron
oui effectivement c'est ce que
j'entendais put alors que le thème de la
santé s'inviter sur la campagne des
présidentielles et c'est fort heureux
c'est nécessaire c'est fondamental au vu
de tous les débats et les échanges que
kylie a sur le plateau depuis tout à
l'heure mais en faire un thème de
campagne c'est important certes mais en
fer en revanche une action de mandat
c'est fondamental visiblement la plupart
des candidats à gauche comme à droite
qui ont été cités sur le plateau on un
jour était aux manettes d'une façon ou
d'une autre au cours de ces vingt
dernières années et malheureusement eh
bien on se rend compte qu'ils en sont
encore réduits aujourd'hui en faire un
thème de campagne là où emmanuel macron
et olivier meyrou en ont fait des
actions on pourra dire que ce n'est pas
suffisant ce n'est pas assez c'est ça je
vous l'accordé sûrement mais ce n'est
qu'un début il faut continuer on parlait
tout à l'heure justement de venir
soulager d'un point de vue financier les
hôpitaux mais également d'un point de
vue humain et là ça veut dire qu'il
s'agit de recruter je suis d'accord mais
pour recruter vous êtes d'accord avec
moi qu'il faut former et c'est la
première fois qu'on a eu la suppression
du numerus clausus mais qu'on a eu aussi
l'augmentation des places en institut de
formation rien que sur cette année c'est
6000 places en plus pour les instituts
de formation aides soignants et
infirmiers
donc encore une fois bien évidemment il
faut que ce sujet s'invite sur la
campagne des présidentielles
mais attention à ne pas faire qu'un
thème de campagne et en faire des
actions comme cela a été le cas au cours
de ces cinq dernières années
poursuivant sur ce qui a été fait sans
venir se griser sur cela mais on
poursuivant l'action est plus que de
chercher des grands mots des grands
thèmes regardons le concret du concret
parce que finalement c'est ce que nos
soignants réclamer c'est ce que
j'entendais piotta lors sur le plateau
en réalité merci encore une fois prisca
thévenot 2
intervenir comme ça en direct dans notre
dans notre émission voilà c'était quand
même important il ya pas mal de
critiques exprimées contre l'action du
gouvernement
donc c'était important d'avoir une voix
de défense de ce bilan je voudrais faire
faire un focus sur l'état de la
situation à l'instant t parce que y'a
bon voilà il ya pas mal de chiffres liés
à la crise qu vide ça c'est olivier
ferrand qui disait un malade toutes les
6 minutes qui entre en réanimation alors
que c'était un malade toutes les 10
minutes la semaine dernière et puis
après on est allé avec qui elle passe
elle à la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission chercher le nombre de
patients qu'aux vite qui sont
hospitalisés aujourd'hui on en a près de
14000 dont 2539 en soins critiques ce
sont les chiffres d'hier est donc on a
cherché le pic le pire depuis depuis
deux ans et avril 2020 on était à 32
mille patients qu'aux vide et plus de
7000 en soins critiques alors je
voudrais bien comprendre comment vous
vous devez de l'intérieur benjamin aussi
parce que là comme moi moi je vois ces
chiffres ni bonbons on a encore de la
marge sauf que depuis un nombre de lits
qui avec l ac a fermé on a perdu des
soignants des lycées ça alors il ya on a
su perdu des soignants de délits et de
la motivation
en vrai
il ya la concorde qu'on a connue pendant
la première vague ne bouge pas un peu
dans le doubs
est en gros on a nous au départ ça a été
une source d'angoissé avec des patients
qui arrivent et partout on savait pas
quoi faire et des patients intubés mais
tout l'hôpital n'a fait que du covan sur
notre hôpital on avait on a un hôpital
de on va dire 400 lits de médecine sur
les 410 médecine en avait 250 qui était
qu'il y avait des patients qu'aux vide
et donc on faisait plus que ça arrivait
plus qu'une maladie dans tout l'hôpital
parce que aussi il faut dire que les
chiffres d'avril il était sûr de région
c'était c'est l ile de france et s est
le grand est donc c'était un gros gros
pic mais c'était vraiment principalement
sur deux régions donc c'était énorme ce
qu'ils avaient à l'hôpital mais donc
là là et je peux vous dire il ya 3000
2500 en soins critiques on est proche
d'être proche de craquer c'est alors en
fait ce qu'il veut ce qui se passe ce
qui se passe
entre temps il ya eu un départ un nombre
de départs hallucinant d'infirmiers des
soignants et que je voudrais dire à un
air ils partent sans chômage sans rien
ils ont dû gérer la crise pendant deux
ans tout le monde est au chômage partiel
et ils partent ils ont droit 0-1 parce
que quand on travaille dans la fonction
publique et compare on touche rien du
tout et je veux juste le dire parce que
c'est des gens qu'ils vont qui sont
traumatisés par ce qu'ils ont vécu
qu'ils partent parce qu'ils sont épuisés
mon leur donnant mes jeux pour en
revenir à ce qui se passe c'est que nous
on est passé des équipes de soignants on
avait 22 23 soignants qui était
titulaire à 7 donc qu'est ce que vous
voulez alors bien sûr il ya des bus ont
réussi à maintenir des lits ouverts mais
en fait c'est hyper en confortable on
peut plus faire du dépassement de
fonction il n'y a plus de il ya plus de
il ya plus de personnel on a des
soignants qui sont épuisés quand on
demande à certains de spécialistes qui
disent ben en fait moi j'ai fait du coc
vie pendant cette crise est en fait
maintenant on me donne des chiffres
d'activité on ne donne pas d'argent
parce que j'ai pas été rentable sur mon
activité première est que si ça continue
comme ça vu qu'un projet de fusion entre
trois hôpitaux parce que
l'administration a décidé de fusionner
des activités trois hôpitaux si on fait
moins d'activités que le service c'est
nos services qui va fermer
où les gens la logique précédente
continue c'est la logique précédentes ça
continue d'appliquer ce qui vous a fait
du comité disent je veux pas me faire
avoir je vais pas faire de covin ils
veulent pas prendre les patients les
patients restent aux urgences pendant
une semaine il faut remplacer outrance
directeurs d'hôpitaux enfin moi ce que
j'entends d'un point de vue tout à fait
profane c'est que vous avez
une mauvaise direction de l'hôpital sans
mauvais si mais si vous dites quoi
laisser des mouvements de part j'ai
acheté on essaie de regrouper les
hôpitaux entre eux pour faire des
économies entre les donc alléger à
acheter j'ai acheté ça veut dire quoi
sceller groupe hospitalier territorial
d'accord alors quand on est dans le 93
qu'on a des hôpitaux qui sont à une
heure les uns des autres on a un bassin
de 1,8 million d'habitants quasiment
comme paris avec dix fois moins
d'hôpitaux 10 et 7 fois moins 10 de
réanimation comment etc on dit qu'il
faut les poulets pour encore 10 minutes
et pour essayer centralisée qu'il faut
les filets en fait c'est des décès des
deux crimes qui ont été remplacés par la
grèce qui essaient des doctrines des
directeurs de j'ai acheté sait déjà
c'est déjà des jets des choses qui sont
en train d'être mises en application et
donc forcément les gens par rapport à ça
sont beaucoup plus en difficulté et donc
tout juste pour dire ce que vous le
prenez urgence les urgences elle déborde
actuellement on n'a plus un seul
praticien aux urgences dont il ya plus
des vacataires les patients restent deux
à trois jours aux urgences sans avoir de
nuit d'hospitalisation 20% de nos lits
sont fermés sur l'hôpital nous à titre
personnel je parle de mon hôpital je
vois pas des chiffres nationaux donc on
est dans cette problématique là
effectivement on n'est pas capable de
gérer le flux malades bizarre est ce
qu'on pouvait parce que c'est quand même
compliqué essayons de se mettre un peu à
la place du midi de la santé confrontés
à une crise comme celle là est ce qu'on
pouvait lancer la grande réforme dont
vous parlez sert tout remettre à plat en
plein milieu de cette crise sanitaire je
veux dire alors d'abord il ya une crise
sanitaire à gérer c'est pour ça que je
dis que le le ségur de la santé on peut
le critiquer mais à ce moment il fallait
bien la passe et s'est créé sauf que
cette crise elle dure plus que ce que ce
à quoi on s'attendait et donc vous avez
les effets d'un délitement du système
hors crise sanitaire qui viennent qui
kevin qui lui continue qui viennent
s'ajouter à sa juste quand même parce
que je pense qu'elle est très sincère la
prévenue était là et qu'il existe un
péno et elle dit mais elle a
l'impression qu'on a mis le sujet sur la
table mais je suis désolé moi j'ai pas
entendu un seul candidat quel que soit
le parti dire il va falloir vraiment
qu'on restructure le système de la santé
qu'on réfléchisse à l'ensemble du modèle
donc le sujet n'est pas sur la salle
présent dans l'ensemble des programmes
sur le temps et les siens mais c'est pas
le point central des
délits et on peut pas faire trente
réformes systémiques dans un quinquennat
si obama il a dit moi mon premier mandat
je n'ai fait qu'une seule réforme
systémique cesser la santé et mon
deuxième mandat j'ai passé l'essentiel
de mon deuxième mandat défend mais
c'était extrêmement compliqué de
réformer un système de santé j'ai pas
qu'il ya que ça à faire loin de là
m'enfin donc c'est une crise comme in
non mais donc oui mais je viens mon
deuxième point c'est que j'ai
l'impression que la reine que le
ministre a l'impression d'avoir
déclenché une réforme structurelle mais
je suis désolé dans le système dans le
secteur de la santé il n'y a que des
dépenses supplémentaires nécessaires
comme ça a été dit mais il ya zéro
réforme actuelle qui pour la plupart ne
nécessite aucune dépense supplémentaire
d'accord que les j'ai acheté la
fonctionnement des ars commente
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce n'est
parce que parce qu'il n'ya pas de
réflexion globale ou depuis trois ans
nous travaillons une centaine qui a
permis d'arriver à ce livre avec aussi
bien la cgt que des mouvements les plus
libéraux donc on a vu d'abord savez ça
peut pas se faire sans consensus donc
c'est pas une réforme de gauche et pas
une réforme de droite c'est une réforme
systémique pour un nouveau modèle de
santé qui va faire les 50 prochaines
années donc il faut mettre les gens
autour d'une table donc là il ya une
responsabilité politique pour qu'il ya
un débat alors et mais il n'y a pas il
n'ya pas d'abord on est dans un système
de contraintes fort on m'a crié une
femme dont on ne va pas parler
aujourd'hui mais qui est essentiel que
dont on ne parle plus qu'à la santé
publique c'est à dire travailler sur la
population en bonne santé pour cette
espérance de vie sans incapacité
augmente en france vous savez qu'on a
les inégalités sociales de santé parmi
les plus élevés d'europe que l'on a des
résultats de prévention parmi les plus
mauvais d'europe et il n'y a pas un seul
euro supplémentaire depuis cinq ans mais
depuis longtemps qui ont été dépensés
pour ça donc nous perdons aussi
énormément de puissance de capacité à
aller j'ai notamment le poids qui pèse
sur l'hôpital et sur les soignants en
s'occupant des gens bien portants bruit
et tout ça c'est une politique à mettre
en place est-ce que c'est pas trop tard
c'est horrible ce que je vais dire je
discutais avec un ami j'ai discuté avec
un ami médecin dans la région nantaise
qui cette façon sur le moral des
[Musique]
témoignages
le partage
c'est le second oui je veux dire on peut
le dire comme ça au détour d'une
conversation assez tard oui c'est tard
la crise en plus à l'ap a révélé est là
elle a décuplé le problème de l'hôpital
donc voilà mais moi je suis complètement
d'accord sur le fait alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle ait loupé qu'est-ce qu'il a
loupé ségur je crois qu'il a loupé
quelque chose de fondamentalement c'est
la décentralisation
très sincèrement c'est à dire qu'on a
parlé de beaucoup de choses et on peut
pas dire que rien n'a été fait ou un jeu
je soutiens investissement leur prise de
la dette l'augmentation des salaires in
à soutenir le voulez oui c'est mais
c'est pas c'est pas en soi c'est penser
à une transformation de notre système de
santé c'est des mesures qui est
absolument de rattrapage nécessaire mais
on n'est pas sur une transformation du
système de santé qui aujourd'hui devient
obligatoire et quand on dit système de
santé mois de transformation je pense
qu'il ya également d'un stress de
transformation 1 la décentralisation est
ce que l'état peut tout gérer dans les
régions est ce que les régions
aujourd'hui qui sont des méga régions
non pas lors leur
concentration c'est l'état donc moi je
suis conseiller régional sur des sujets
de santé et on voit bien que la rs on
tend la main dans le grand test on
essaye de travailler c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que c'est une
déconcentration mais c'est pas une
décentralisation donc moi je pense qu'à
la décentralisation qui devrait
s'inviter dans le débat présidentiel
et la deuxième chose c'est la prévention
c'est quand même la prévention
aujourd'hui on a des maladies qui
pourraient être évitable mais est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'on mobilise assez
d'argent sur la prévention banon on en
mobilise pas assez et peut-être et après
j'arrête la table la troisième chose que
l'on pourrait donc là déconcentre la
décentralisation la prévention et c'est
ensuite une question aussi de faire
travailler les gens ensemble de la
gouvernance des systèmes la gouvernance
des hôpitaux l'hôpital s'est bien
débrouillé quand ils ont dû se
débrouiller pendant la quinzaine ce soit
quand on les a laissés qu'on a lâché les
brides qu'on les a laissé travailler il
était dans un marasme pas possible et
ils s'en sont bien sortis ils ont
réorganisé en deux temps trois
mouvements ils ont réorganisé leurs cils
avez vous donné le mot de la fin
mais je voudrais quand même rappeler ont
l'air fois qu'on a parlé de l'hôpital
ici on avait en
duplex le directeur l'hôpital de
valenciennes c'est un peu le contre
exemple en matière de l'administration
lui l'a totalement déléguée aux chefs de
service c'est pouvoir résultat est plus
que 5 % de personnels administratifs au
lieu de
chaque fois ne s'étaient envenimées
pourquoi on ne fait pas partager ce que
vous pour vous c'est un élément central
ça le fait de redonner aux chefs de
service finalement la main je crois
qu'il faut surtout redonné en fait au
fond le rôle d'un hôpital c'est de
drainer une demande territoriale de
patients donc nous notre objectif et moi
c'est pour ça que je suis on a tous un
peu désespérée c'est qu'on voit depuis
depuis la troisième bac on n'est plus
capable de gérer la demande de nos
territoires cirque ont fait des patients
affluent et les médecins se voit le voit
les patients et doivent organiser la
demande enfin l'offre de soin en
fonction de la demande de soins donc les
médecins se disent quasiment cas on ne
réussit pas à passer ces patients là il
faut monter ça et c'est donc ça devrait
être les médecins qu'ils soient qui
décide ce qui est de faire remonter aux
administrations ce qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui il ya une direction qui est
effectivement complètement complètement
pyramidale et qui vient de
l'administratif qui sont tout en haut
qui ont des marqueurs et des indicateurs
je ne sais pas lesquels mais qui ne sont
pas efficients finalement sur le terrain
sur la nécessité du terrain et on
devrait utiliser en fait en premier lieu
la demande des patients ensuite comment
on fait pour les fédérer auprès de
médecins puis après comment on fait pour
les financer au niveau de
l'administration mais ça devrait être
comme ça plutôt que se passer dans ses
rangs termine là dessus merci beaucoup
merci
rappel le titre de votre livre majeur
aussi c'est en première ligne alors ici
de l'intérieur c'est chez prisma édition
et fédérer bizarre l'autonomie solidaire
en santé la seule réforme possible aux
éditions michalon merci à tous encore